All right, we have a number of new people on here this week.
Most people chat in any questions that they weren't able to send in.
Remember send your questions in via the form.
It's on multiple pages of the members site.
The members only site.
That's the site that only you have access to.
So there's multiple pages that have a blue box where you can submit your Zoom call questions.
Please do that over there.
If you can think of them beforehand, but I know as we go through this, you think a question.
You can chat those questions in.
And do my best to answer them.
And if I don't really answer, I will tell you that too.
Okay, the other housekeeping that we always talk about.
Make sure you look at the member site for any updates on.
You have talked about the checking your group.
Who's that following that for some time in the free access.
You have to all the courses.
So make sure you take advantage of that as well.
And look at the Zoom calls or the blog posts too.
Um, there could be questions that are answered on the blog posts that we might have.
So you don't have to wait until next Wednesday for your question to be answered.
Okay, question number one.
What would stop?
Product skeet it.
A large areas of the body.
Further.
Could this be caused by a dysfunction of my kidneys or liver from my previous diagnosed Hodgkin's lymphoma?
For several weeks, I've had almost constant itching training with copy animals.
Landling, article that writes itching programs with little success.
The skin is also very dry.
The almost constant itching is a rather painful and causing stress.
So there's lots of reasons for skin for itching skin.
And the rashes, depending on if you have a rationed on or raised and lots of different questions that should be asked.
But the key component here is this component right here, the lymphoma.
So for some reason that isn't fully understood that one of the symptoms of lymphoma.
All sorts of types of lymphoma is itchy skin itchy.
As a matter of fact, that can be the first sign of lymphoma.
I'd say a person doesn't have a diagnosis, doesn't know that they have any issue.
And then they have this severe itching.
And that's what ends up bringing to the doctor.
They do a blood test and then they find out they have one photo.
The elevated blood cell tone, etc.
So having a previous diagnosis lymphoma.
And that's the first thing that you need to look at is their optic of lymphoma.
And you want to get some going to get some blood work done.
That's the first thing you should think of because that is so common with lymphoma.
Now there are some people with lymphoma that never get this symptom.
And there are some that do other pieces of skin itchy and itchy.
And that can be the blockage of the bowel duct.
So if the belly room and the blood test is elevated, you'll often a person will see severe itching throughout their body.
So that's another issue.
There's all sorts of reasons a person could have a allergic reaction to something that have achieved all over their body.
And there's a lot of reasons with inflammation in the gut could cause itchy in the skin.
There is a gut skin connection neurologically and metabolically.
So I guess the first step for me with somebody with a previous diagnosis of lymphoma would be to get a full blood workup.
And that would be the first thing.
If that has been done and you feel like, oh, no, I talked to my oncologist, I did get one work and there's anything to do with that.
Then you have to investigate other things and we should set up a full consultation because we may want to investigate the gut issues, we've set the timneys, et cetera.
My son needs orthodontic work done and I wondered if metal braces or a visoline is the better option.
Is there one that is less toxic to have it as well?
Well, I think the visoline is less toxic.
It's a plastic, plastic tray, but I think you're getting less toxins from that than you're getting from metal braces.
And there's the metal braces, stainless steel that's holding on to your teeth with a clamp to use a paste that is going to basically cement them onto the teeth.
So there's toxins that are involved with that.
That being said, there are sometimes that the visoline will work for people.
So you have to talk to multiple different orthodontists to see what is going to be best for that person's mouth because, you know, depending on what is the to be done if it's a wide in the palate, if you might need to get an expander beforehand, there's just lots of different things that go on with that.
I'm not going to give advice about orthodontic work, but from a toxicity level, I think you're better off with the invisoline.
This is a follow on the question below I am having severe leg cramps almost early in the morning on a daily basis when I finished my chemo three years ago, I was told to take I believe 800 milligrams of calcium every day.
I take algecal plus and osteo force with TVGO and ADK also.
So I take them on alternate days, I have taken four infusions in Zomena six months apart.
The last infusion was nearly a year ago, I believe I may be taking too much calcium in my potassium levels may be off effectiveness.
Am I taking too much calcium? What are your thoughts about anti potassium? I took an MRI of my feet and legs on the recommendation of the podiatrist to see if I implant her fasciitis but have not received the results yet.
Your thoughts there my legs ache when I walk or have to climb steps.
It does not stop me from walking and doing exercise in my right leg, I believe, has some neuropathy as a result of the genome therapy, see who 2020 could indicate vascular problems, what do you recommend.
So how much calcium should a person take, even if they have osteoporosis or osteolytic metastasis cancer.
The common thought in nutritional circles for a long time has been that you have to increase the calcium if you have osteoporosis because you have a deficiency in calcium.
Well, if you listen to me for a very long at all, you'll understand that that has been debunked a long time ago by numerous studies and by numerous just understanding the physiology of osteoporosis, even understanding the physiology of bold growth.
If you take the osteo force product, that's a product from size for health, it doesn't have a high dose calcium.
It has other things that will help build bold other nutrients and minerals in there, it doesn't have a high dose calcium.
But ADK and the TVGO have no calcium in it, so really you're a real calcium source as the 800 milligrams of calcium that you're getting in the algae cal plus and combined with what's in the osteo force.
That's really probably too much calcium.
So I would agree with you, obviously whoever asks this question has read some things about calcium because they're asking the question is there's too much calcium, I think the answers yes.
Studies that have been shown where they used to recommend 1500 milligrams of calcium for women, especially on postmenopausal because you have an increase in osteoporosis postmenopausal.
But that has to do with the fluctuation of formal levels that increases inflammation.
So it is really decreasing inflammation in the bowl that's going to help the bone uptake calcium.
So it's not increasing blood calcium levels because if you're going to take a whole bunch of calcium, you're pumping a whole bunch of calcium into the blood, your body cannot have calcium in the blood like that member, your body has to your blood has to be buffered.
That's going to be too much alkalinity in the blood. It's going to push it to the tissues calcium is going to be pushed to the tissues and the blood vessels themselves and it can cause and it has been shown because.
So there's been a huge increase in heart issues and biocardial infarctions and women that have been taking, you know, the recommended 1500 milligrams of calcium that just literally skyrocketed that because there's been books written about it about how you should not be taking.
It's not exogenous meaning it's supplemental for the calcium plus the source of calcium was usually calcium carbonate which makes it even worse.
So no, I think you should probably drop back on your calcium levels. Certainly you could take potassium, but maybe even better yet look at your blood test.
If you are not deficient in potassium, you probably shouldn't be taking any extra potassium if that's not an issue.
Other reasons why you could have legs cramping at things is not usually a calcium issue.
It is a mineral deficiency. It's usually a magnesium deficiency or an iron deficiency. So you have to look at your blood test and make sure that you aren't anemic.
So people that are anemic, we need to have low iron, they will end up having leg cramps and things like that because of the anemia.
So it's a cat you're in a catch 22 if you have a current ongoing cancer because you don't want to necessarily be pumping a whole much iron into the system because iron can be a fuel source of cancer.
But if you're kind of post cancer, you're at a state of remission, there's nothing wrong with taking some iron if you are anemic.
So you take iron based upon your blood test, a CBC would be the blood test that I'm talking about.
Also a CBC and a complete metabolic battle would show calcium levels and potassium levels too.
Other reasons why a person can be have leg cramps, I said magnesium deficiency, that's where leg Epsom salt baths would really be helpful for a person with that and post neuropathy.
So you could have neurological issues causing leg cramps because there's damage to the neurons from a chemical damage from the chemotherapy.
Most people patients tend to have damage of neurons, especially large diameter, effort, neurons, that's the, that's the type of neuron that carries pain and carries tingly if carries hot and cold back to the brain, back to the spinal cord and back to the brain.
Those are the highly metabolic and the most easily damaged with chemotherapy and with diabetic neuropathy as well.
So doing iron pro ways, which leads to the question of the effectiveness of a 50 talks to it, I have pro waves can be helpful for people who have neuropathy.
So I would say do that also that little piece of equipment called the rebuilder, which stimulates the nerve to help grow back if you have neuropathy.
That's not going to help if you have a, you know, a demon or a mineral deficiency, but if you have neuropathy that has to do with the damage of the neurons, then the rebuilder would help with that too.
There's other issues that could cause this to intermittent claudication, we discussed this last week and last week, some call or the week before.
So make sure you look back at that.
I have tons of inflammation, not sure if it's due to chemo pills or mistletoe, but I'm having tons of heat.
Except the day after the IV and vitamin C intrusion, I have life was all the curve clear on hand.
If I take that internally with that help, if so, how much said this female pill, I can't hardly take the green first shake any ideas.
I have to have a PET scan, the doctor wants a baseline, are there any supplements that I should discontinue before the scan.
Last question first, no, there's nothing you should discontinue before the scan, I would go ahead and get the scan. I think that would be good to see what's going on.
I know that chemo changes your taste buds, it really changes your taste buds from a neurological perspective.
So therefore, some things just don't taste well, you don't feel good taking them and eating, that's a problem.
I understand that to give you any ideas, try to change the taste by adding other things to it, berries, chocolate, I don't know, something like that.
Give me a different taste, that would be a nice suggestion.
The lapel was almost curcuclear, would that be good to decrease inflammation?
So what would be good to decrease inflammation are different flavonoids.
So curcumin, yes, the lapel was almost curcuclear, would be good.
How much did you take in that?
You really can't take too much of it.
You really want to get a high dose into decreased inflammation, but it can be good if you have some other flavonoids at home too to have those on hand too, because it can be kind of a synergistic effect if you use other flavonoids too, like Boswellia.
And then from green tea extract can be helpful.
The barks like pine bark extract can be helpful.
It's corseted, can be helpful.
Grobalate, which is an enzyme, but it can be helpful.
And then grobalin, which is the product from Beats, which the aloevia created, that is very helpful for some people with pain too.
That is called limitless by aloevia.
That can be very helpful. That's helped a lot of people with pain, CBD, THC, those are all the things that you think of decrease inflammation or decrease pain.
My husband recently had his lap tonsil with a tumor removed not hunch because lymphoma.
He has been 13 days now and just getting off the pain meds and able to return to normal foods.
There remains swelling in the neck and lymph nodes.
When may he return to the hyperbaric oxygen treatments, high dose vitamin C drips and far infrared sauna treatments.
Thank you kindly.
I would say you could start those now for sure.
I don't think you're going to have any issue with hyperbaric oxygen.
I don't think you're going to have any issue with the vitamin C drips.
Because it is increasing your temperature and can increase some inflammation temporarily.
So just watch that.
If you feel like you're getting a little swelling, I would go slow on the soda.
That's all I would say.
But otherwise everything else you could go ahead and take and pray for him.
I know he was going to go ahead with that surgery.
So glad that he's doing a little.
I had estrogen receptive receptor progestinal receptor positive breast cancer.
I am seeing a doctor for emotional trauma and anxiety.
She noticed in her scans on her third mug roughly that a pituitary is not functioning properly.
She recommends these supplements, standard process pituitary pmg, hypothelmus pmg and hypothelmix.
So three are taken three times at breakfast, three times a dinner, possibly for three weeks.
Nervous because of four motor receptive positive breast cancer.
And what are it if that may affect my hormones or conflict with the large supplement arrangement that I'm currently on.
The two atrofen is derived from bovine, gerutary extract.
That sounds a little scary.
I live with germany, very bad calm outbreak.
What are your thoughts on these supplements all take them together?
Would it be safer or more effective to just run the pituitary normalizing programs on the right.
So I know you are taking a lot of supplements.
So I know you are concerned about adding more to your region.
So you have to weigh that out as well.
So what are the standard process pituitary pmg and hypothelmus pmg and hypothelmix.
They are what pmg stands for proto morphogen.
So proto morphogen is the organ glandular nutrition.
So this is glandular nutrition.
And yes, it is going to be derived from bovine tissue, meaning it's going to be derived from cows.
So this is cow, pituitary cow, hypothelmus tissue.
And that's what you are consuming.
Is there a danger with this?
People say, oh my gosh, this is going to lead to bad cow disease.
Is there a danger to this?
No, there is no danger to that for that at all.
I would not be concerned with that at all.
They take it to clean organic animals, all the companies that we've ever used.
We don't sell a standard process because of other reasons.
But this is a good product.
You don't have to have any issues taking that.
Is there a danger in taking pituitary or hypothelmus nutrition if you have PR positive cancer?
No, there's no danger in that whatsoever.
Either that's not going to increase your estrogen production.
So I would not worry about that.
It's just building blocks for your pituitary.
So I don't think there's any harm in taking that.
So would it be easier just to run the would it be safer to run the pituitary?
I wouldn't think it's safer.
The would it be cheaper for you?
Yes.
Would it be less supplements?
Could you do both?
Yes.
So that's a decision you'll have to make.
But there isn't any harm in taking this.
I shared with you my artimistic protocol.
I am starting in a few days.
I also read it by my local functional doctor.
She has many unartimistic for many things.
I was just wondering if you had any comments or things to add.
I know there was someone else on here that had bone metastatic issues.
I still have not heard back from oncologists.
So no reason to wait any longer.
Paid is high level of times of managing.
So again, like we shared last week or the week before I think artimistic is great.
And there's no harm in adding it to your protocol.
It has been shown that effect.
I just, I think I just updated a blog post on artimistic with some new information.
So look at that blog post.
I think I don't think there's really any harm in taking artimistic.
Unless a person is just taking way too many.
So that would be my only concern is that if a person just taking way too much stuff.
Maybe artimistic is not best to add to your protocol.
But yeah, go for it.
I think it's a great addition.
Artimistic is not going to be really, you know, you said your pain isn't high level.
Artimistic is a really a pain decrease or no.
So maybe think of some of the other things that I talked about and the other question about helping.
When I had my port surgery on June 7th, they told me after that I had been given antibiotics.
I knew I should start probiotics, but I felt ill immediately and forgot to do so on the hindsight.
Might some of my symptoms itchy eggs and a type rash on my chest torso, armpits, vaginal rectal itch and white tongue be from that initial antibiotic.
It took lots of probiotics through the month of July when I was on a 5V antibiotics per staff.
But those initial symptoms remain I am following a high protein low card mostly meat and vegetables.
In fact, I do about two cups may go in a smoothie and maybe an apple a day doesn't sound like yeast or Candida.
If so, how do I get rid of it?
It can be certainly Candida infection given, you know, your amount of antibiotic use.
It can be not just Candida just microbiotta just overgrowth of different things and imbalance in your microbiota.
So that's very possible.
I also admit that many antibiotics quite possibly have damaged your intestinal lining and cause disnot only dysbiosis of the intestinal track, but issues with your tight junctions of the epithelial cells that's called the link you got issues.
You certainly could have developed food sensitivities.
Maybe you had put some sensitivity for that and this just brought it out and increased the amount of antibodies that you had to different foods. It's not uncommon.
Even if person didn't have take a lot of antibiotics, so you're not protected from damage to the epithelial lining of the gut by taking probiotics.
Probiotics can help if your if a person has to be on an antibiotics, probiotics are definitely recommended and will be help to manage the degree of dysbiosis that a person will suffer from, you know, being a longer term antibiotics.
However, it doesn't give you protection against the damage that you're going to, that's going to sue on the epithelial lining of the gut, which can then lead to, you know, things crossing the gut border that shouldn't kept times of foods crossing the gut border that shouldn't and you developing antibodies to those foods.
And now you have to manage that and start working on healing that.
So, you know, in a perfect world, I would run the Syrex panel array two array three X array four array 10 on a person that came to me with these type of symptoms.
You have to get to some causes some reasons why I know those things can be expensive. So a lot of people can't do those things.
Then you have to decide how you're going to try to handle those trying to, you know, clean up the most common food sensitivities get rid of gluten in your diet, get rid of dairy in your diet.
See how that works to a food elimination type process. So you have to work through those things call it. We might be going to okay.
As to a couple of weeks ago about the reason and cure for cystic acne.
I've not been able to find this in call again. Could you please advise will cystic acne is definitely.
It's a link to got issues. So this is the got skin pathway.
Is so common, you know, people that have dysbiosis get it up with rashes and acne people that have.
H. Pylora very common that they end up with skin rashes and actually hair loss all sorts of things like that that are really common to that gut.
If the gut health going back to that gut health is the key component.
Disbiosis is an issue and antibodies are an issue decreasing inflammation being important thing.
I've always said to receive it in April but using my right for your programs overnight.
However, I get intense pain. I think it's now get tense pain when I use the right now.
It's a painful enough to not be able to sleep and already struggling with the zombie. The pain is is tolerable during the day.
Since I'm not trying to sleep, but I'm trying to be more active and shouldn't sit for eight to nine hours.
I don't want to stop using the right but night. Could you please advise. I would just say move the bulb a little bit further away.
Look at the blog post that says good pain, bad pain. That would be going back to the blog and searching pain and look at my video and good pain, bad pain, I think that would help.
You have to sleep so you have to balance that with sleep. Maybe start with moving the bulb a little bit farther away and see if that will decrease the pain that you'll still get some benefit from using the bulb.
I'm still having staff induced in zombie. I was told this would go away when the infection was gone but according to cultures, I've had infection free.
I don't stand for over a month and off of antibiotics for almost two weeks. It's getting very slowly better.
As I am up to almost four hours a night, the last few days, however, I need more and better sleep in order to heal. I never fall asleep before two thirty.
And even when I go to bed at nine o'clock like you advise and do not use electronics before bed except listening to my Bible would help try to fall asleep. I'm struggling with restless legs and which contributes to the insomnia.
I am using magnesium oil in my legs and doing some bedtime yoga. These sometimes seem to help but not always can you advise on both the insomnia and restless legs.
Well, restless legs. I know magnesium oil is, it was a really hot topic about 10 years ago when it first came out.
Firstly, we carried it in our store. We used it on some patients. I tried it personally.
The problem is magnesium. The minerals are in the form of a salt.
So, minerals have to be bonded to something and the magnesium in the magnesium oil, I think, is a magnesium chloride. So, it's a salt.
And it dries and then you have a salt on your skin to have this white kind of salty layer on your skin which can become itchy and it's not really well absorbed.
I drew to be not a fan of magnesium oil and I discontinued carrying it and discontinued recommending it because I don't think it was shown to be well absorbed at all.
And I think the magnesium salt in water is even better absorbed because oil is not absorbed well through your skin.
So, I think taking magnesium baths in an epsom salt is better for you as far as your absorption of magnesium and can be more soothing to your skin and you get less itch.
So, you still may have some magnesium salts on your skin after an epsom salt bath. I don't think you get as much as you see the oil. That's just my tape.
Secondly, so go back to our question that an earlier listener had about restless legs issues. So, making sure that there isn't any other causes restless legs which might have nothing to do with magnesium might have to do with iron might have to do with other minerals might have to do with other things.
Also, with the insomnia, there's lots of different beneficial herbs for insomnia that can help calm your brain.
You could try using GABA that can help calm your brain knowing full well that GABA is a large molecule and if it does work to help calm your brain that doesn't does indicate that you actually have blood brain barrier issues, but a lot of people have blood brain barrier issues.
So, if you're on antibiotics for that long and dealing with everything you have, you might very well have blood brain issues. There's nothing wrong with using it to your advantage and getting GABA across there, which is a call me neural transmitter using different using melatonin.
melatonin can be beneficial using higher dose melatonin, which can be good for cancer, IP beneficial.
I tried to get some exercise before bed. I think I have a number of blog posts on the insomnia and there's lots of different things on Google which you can find that can be helpful for insomnia too.
And I think there was one question there.
When I was struggling so much in Judah, I added a lot of supplements in order to feel better. If I said you a current list, can you advise me on what to get to take?
Sure, you said that with a cheek swam. So, send it a cheek swab with a current list of supplements and I will check and see what I think you should be doing next.
Make sure you send me in the form with the cheek swab as stated on the riverside clues.
How does one know if their gallbladder and liver are working efficiently? You speak much about that in the seven pages of detox, but I'm missing how to know if they are functioning well.
That popied one is obvious, the others not so much.
So, how to know if your gallbladder is working? Well, there are some questions that you could ask. I'm actually making some new videos on gallbladder function.
But the questions you could ask are me do how do I tolerate fatty foods? Well, yeah, I have no trouble to or some people might say they can just talk to somebody the other day. It said no, you know, I tolerate them really well.
I said good that you can eat fatty foods with only problems. Oh, no, I never eat fatty foods. Why don't you eat fatty foods because they cause me problems? Well, then you don't tolerate them very well.
So if you can't tolerate fatty foods and a side of gallbladder issues, certainly there's blood tests that can show that you have gallbladder issues, meaning that if you have elevated really rumored that we know you have some blockage in the bile duct most commonly.
But functional gallbladder issues, the most the most appropriate way to diagnose functional gallbladder issues is to get it ultrasound.
So you get an ultrasound of your gallbladder to see, you know, really how much sludge slash gallstones that you have in a gallbladder. That would be the thing to do.
So I have gallbladder flush information on the seventh path, the seven phases of these talks course that you could look at to and just supporting the gallbladder in all of you are supporting the gallbladder.
If you're following if you're doing coffee in a mess and you're doing Kestrel packs and hot packs over your gallbladder liver area. So that's what we have all of you doing that.
So if you are doing that, you are supporting the gallbladder. How do you know if your liver is working correctly.
Well, the you cannot there isn't any test out there as far as lab to know how your liver pathways are all efficient.
They're working. When we look at your genetics, we look at do you have any defects in the center for people for 50 in the pod pathway and the net pathways, et cetera, et cetera, to look if you have defects in phase one phase two phase three liver pathways.
But that doesn't tell us functionally how efficiently they're working. Now, we can get some clues to liver functionality by looking at a complete metamorphic pathway in the AST, ALT, GGT,
alkaline phosphatase will tell us if those are elevated can tell us that there is inflammation in the liver person is elevated cholesterol can tell us that there's some sort of inflammation in the liver for sure.
Does that tell us the efficiency of the detox pathways. There's no way to know that except other symptoms. So by a toxic person because I because you know, there's there's other evidence of toxins meeting
like symptoms like rashes and you know, just feeling ill health and having a diagnosis of cancer, then we just want to support those pathways. So it's, it's, you don't even need to look at a person's genetics for their detox pathways to know that everybody needs some help with their detox pathways.
The truth is is that you're detoxing constantly and you want to decrease the amount of toxicification that's happening on a constant basis so that you are detoxing at a greater rate than your toxic.
That's not even worth that your toxifying yourself. It's probably not a word either. So following to what to increase your rate of detoxification. So you do everything you can possibly within reason to help support that.
So having, you know, getting an ultrasound of your gallbladder to make sure that there's not, it's just not a lot of back up there can be helpful, especially if you're going to go there, you're have gone through chemo and you've gone through, you know, a lot of talks and, you know, issues in your, in your lifetime that could be helpful.
Okay, questions that you can, can you please discuss the value of effectiveness of the foot detox.
So I think I touched on that a little bit. I think that can be beneficial. I told all of you that personally, I don't do that at all anymore.
But I was really sick. I did that a few times at the office, but I don't, I just told somebody today that I don't think I ever did it at home.
Do I, is it because I didn't think there's value in it? No, it's just that you have to weigh out what you can do, you know, when I was doing, you know, I saw that I was doing the PDF, I was doing the right constantly.
And plus I was working full time, you know, and you just have to weigh out. Plus I had a life to live and I have a bunch of grandkids and kids and wife to tend to and, you know, you have to weigh what you can do.
And I didn't want treating my cancer to become a God in my life. So you, I, some things had to go and, and doing the, I am pro wave. Sorry, true right, but I didn't do it. I, you know, but some of you think, oh, wow, I just find so much value.
And then it really helps. Well, then by all means do that. So you just kind of, you got to weigh out what's going to be best for you.
If you haven't done it yet, I would do it and see how you like it. Some people love it. Just absolutely love it. And, and continue to do it. We have people on this call maybe that are did do it every single day because they think it just helps them so much. So,
is the microwave evil since I am on a low history diet and immediately freeze left over food. I use it to defrost so I don't have to cook every day.
I also make big batches of my coffee and a little more of it in the microwave. Is this okay?
Well, this is my opinion. So I use the microwave, you know, you know, a couple of my kids don't have a microwave in their house, but my wife and I use the microwave.
And yes, does it use waves that keep the coffee, you know, or the food, whatever you're heating up.
You know, at a high level and couldn't denature the proteins and that's basically what the argument is is a can denature the proteins in the food and it doesn't.
But, you know, it's again, it's like it's like the iron Broadway. It's like you can't, you know, we do a lot of things right.
Okay, I think my wife and I and our family do a lot of things right. But if we, you know, you can you see these Instagram posts of these people that are that are into healthy limited.
It's like, are you kidding? Is this how you actually live? Can anybody? This is your whole focus is on, you know, don't do this and do this and don't do this.
Your anxiety level must be through the lasted rule, you know, it's like you can't settle down and calm down and go, okay, well, this is a choice I'm going to make.
We're going to use the microwave. Maybe someday I'll go, hey, we're not going to use the microwave. We're going to use this.
But the truth is we cheat up leftover food all the time in the microwave and I have to heat up my coffee at the office three times in the microwave because I, you know, every time I make a coffee, I drink a little bit of it that it sits there and I forget about it.
I go heating up in the microwave and it sits in the microwave for an hour because I forgot I put it in the microwave.
So you have to weigh things out on what you can do and can't do. Yeah, the perfect world would we not use the microwave. No, but probably not, but in the world that we live in.
You know, I probably shouldn't be on the computer all day. It's probably not going to vibrate either, but I have to because that's what I do. So you have to weigh those things out.
You should lipozomal glutathione be taken with a meal with fat in it for better absorption. No, you can take it any time. It is a lipozomal soul.
By definition, lipozomal nutrients are wrapped in a fact. So you don't need to take it with a fatty meal to absorb it. Plus it's very small. You don't really need a lot of bio to help absorb it either.
You have enough already that got even for those without a gold ladder and you'll secrete lipase from your papers as well.
I used to be on zeolite and put that in my greens first rig since it was discontinued. So you're this person's talking about a product called zeolite.
I was actually with a z, I think, from Premier Research Land. So since that was discontinued, so Premier's research doesn't have that product anymore. I've been an ultra binder.
Several recently said that charcoal can bind to nutrients to and not just to toxin. Should I take the ultra binder separate from the green string.
So technically you should take your binders on an empty stomach.
It's good to take a binder in the morning and in the evening.
It does act as a binder, but you're not taking zeolite. So all the ultra binder, I would say, yeah, take that. Don't mix it with the greens. That would be perfect.
Again, you know, you know, some people just mix all our stuff together and take it twice a day if they can.
Once a day, if they can't, you just have to have a balance in your life. Yeah, in a perfect world, take your binders away from food. That's the best way to do.
I may have any issues with insomnia for the last four to six months. I've tried magnesium 3.0.
So the magnesium, this magnesium L3 and 8 is the way it's bound also is called into the brain, the 3 and 8 part.
At magnesium glycinate without success, it seems that I went, I went to a more of a plant-based diet, less meat, the insomnia began.
So, um, THC works, but I really don't want to become dependent any recommendations. So, um, what can't, so another, so there's multiple reasons why a person can't fall asleep or they fall asleep and they wake up and they can't stay asleep.
What else to do with cortisol levels, so which I didn't talk about earlier about insomnia. This is a big issue with insomnia and more commonly with the inability to get back to sleep once the person wakes up at that to get up to go to the bathroom or something.
So, um, that's the best way to fall back asleep. Um, that is more of a cortisol issue and that has to do with stress, dealing with stress in your life, dealing with the anxiety in your heart is really, really important.
The best way to handle cortisol, but one little trick can be to eat some protein before you go to bed. So, eat a piece, check it before you go to bed and see if that makes a difference.
Do that for a week, eat, you know, half a chicken breast before you go to bed and see if that makes a difference and give that a try.
Also, what could help if stress is your issue is using adaptogens. So we talked a lot about adaptogens.
That adaptogens can be very calming and, you know, different adaptogenic glens can have gamma in it. So I mentioned gamma before.
And gamma, technically it's into the adaptogenic herb, gamma is during transmitter, it's a call me to a transmitter, but it is commonly in different adaptogenic on nutrient blends.
And using a rebounder to my fitness routine, anything else that will help my lymph nodes do their job. As you know, I'm trying to get them to be clear when they take a few during my upcoming surgery.
Well, your lymph nodes, your lymph vessels do not have heart that pumps the lymph through them, your lymph nodes and your lymph vessels rely on contraction of your muscles. So using your muscles contracting, using doing some weights, doing any muscle contracting things can be helpful moving your body is the biggest thing that's going to help your lymph vessels.
How high a dose of melatonin? Well, typically a person will take three milligrams of melatonin to help fall asleep. They can go up to nine to 12 milligrams to help fall asleep.
But that's really not a chance or, you know, killer dose melatonin cancer killer dose melatonin is usually about 60 to 180 milligrams melatonin.
The higher dose melatonin doesn't really help you fall asleep anymore. So typically it's recommended that you start with just three milligrams if you're just taking it for sleep, you start with three milligrams of melatonin to help you fall asleep.
But if you're, if it's taking four or five hours for you to fall asleep, make sure you're dealing with some of the other things that we talked about here too.
How do I know if I'm tested have been damaged by the antibiotics, you'd have to do those Syrex panels that we talked about those Syrex blood tests, the two, the three X, the four, and the ten, the array, Syrex array two, array three X array four and array ten.
That's how you would know, definitively, the health of your intestine was where would you suggest to start with curated cystic acne, it's really depends on a person's budget.
So if you had the budget, I would run those tests, but that can cost you a grand in those tests, they're not cheap tests in your church look and cover those.
If that's not in your budget, I would start with trying to help try to heal the gut with with the, you know, removing any things that are possibly causing damage.
So you start by, okay, so if you're making the assumption that a person has, you know, you know, increase permeability of their epithelial cells that are gone for leaking gut issues damage got walls.
There's a reason it is because of the dose of antibiotic, then there is going to be inflammatory cytokines that are going to be developed from that and there's going to be because of the leak you got there's going to be antibodies to different foods.
And the most common ones are when I suggested gluten, getting rid of all gluten in your diet, look at a gluten clock cross reactants, which is dairy, corn, things like that, but you can't just go on such a restrictive diet that you can't eat anything.
So make sure you're eating a lot of different types of vegetables.
But you really want to know what those things are, that's why you do those tests.
And then just maybe doing some things that will help heal the gut, start with the simplest, declarative, licorice, slippery, elm, things like that, we have a product called GI clear GI that can be helpful, that has a powder that has all that got healing things in it.
It's actually by 17 year old son who has the cystic acne, well, then you should do a case review for your 17 year old son, we really shouldn't be asking a lot of questions for our family members on this chat.
So that's a weird, in some cases.
All right, well, we will call it a nightstakes for being on and thanks for another great questions that I think we're going to be helping for everybody.
So know that I'm praying for all of you, and if you have to make an appointment with me, feel free to give greater energy and call and do so and make myself available.
Bye bye.